ich gratuliere ihnen zum tag des großen
sieges die verteidigung des heimatlandes
das schicksal unseres heimatlandes so
waren sie von größter bedeutung
meine damen und herren sie haben uns
verteidigt in borodino in der nähe von
moskau in leningrad in kiew und den weg
ins tal in grad im kurs in silverstone
polin heiko
genauso wie heute
in der heutigen zeit kämpfen sie für
unsere leute interview für die
sicherheit unseres landes und
der neunte mai 1945 ist in die annalen
der geschichte eingeschrieben worden
dies war ein triumph unseres
sowjetischen volkes
seines zusammenhalt unter geistigen
stärke seine heldentaten an der front
und dem rücken der tag des sieges
ist wichtig und wertvoll für alle von
uns es gibt keine einzelne familie die
nicht gelitten hat im großen
vaterländischen krieges an diesem tag
den viele viele menschen auf der straße
mit fotos ihre großeltern und eltern sie
zu sagen diese fotos vor sich sie tragen
dieser fotos von den verstorbenen
soldaten und von den von uns gegangen wo
veteranen wir sind stolz auf dieser
generation auf diese siege generation
wir sind stolz behaupten dass wir ihre
nach waffen
die der nationalsozialismus besiegt
haben die alles dafür getan haben dass
die sich schrecken nicht wiederholt
werden es gibt unstimmigkeiten auf der
internet ein arena aber dennoch hatte
russland immer dafür eingetreten dass
kur sicherheit unteilbar ist für ein
system das wichtig ist für die ganze
welt im dezember letzten jahres wollte
er vertrat
sicherheitsgarantien eingehalten werden
russland hat dazu aufgerufen den westen
dazu aufgerufen dass die interessen
berücksichtigt werden aber das war
umsonst die nato länder wollten nicht
auf uns vor dass sie hatten ganz andere
pläne
und wir wussten dass wir sein dass
wurde darauf vorbereitet eine operation
in dollars durchzuführen in unsere
historische ländern einzudringen
man sprach auch
atomwaffen erhalten werden können von
bestimmten und somit
planmäßig eine situation geschaffen die
für uns und ein drehbares und zwar
unmittelbar vor uns
alles deutet darauf hin dass man ein
zusammenstoß erraten
nationalsozialismus mit bandera leuten
und das alles deutet eher darauf hin
wir haben gesehen wie militärische
infrastruktur
entwickelt werden wie so führen wir
militärberater aus dem ausland auch
herangezogen werden die moderne technik
angeschafft wird und die hydro für jeden
tag größer wir haben einen
präventivschlag
und das war rechtzeitig und die einzig
richtige entscheidung
die entscheidung eines souveränen und
starken landes
eine damen und herren vereinigten
staaten von amerika insbesondere gemacht
im zerfall der sowjetunion
sprachen von ihrer
sie erniedrigten und ich suche die ganze
welt sondern auch ihre satelliten stadt
die so tun als ob sie nicht dass mark
und sie schlucken alle aber wir sind ein
anderes russland hat einen anderen
charakter
wir lieben unser land
wir glauben an traditionelle an
traditionelle werte an unsere vorfahren
verschiedener kulturen wir haben 1000
reiche geschichte oder ganz abgeschafft
werden sollten und diese degradierung
grundlage der falschen interpretation
der ergebnisse der 2
das nicht erhalten das nicht resultieren
des studenten die wissen auch dass es
amerikanische veteranen gab die an der
parade teilnehmen wollt und hier in
moskau ihnen wurde das verboten aber wir
sind stolz auf die heldentaten auch wir
sind stolz auf ihr beitrag diesen
allem
amerikaner briten franzosen allen
widerstand zu kämpfen wenn sie den
chinesischen soldaten all denen die dazu
beigetragen den faschismus in der not
kämpfen die widerstandskämpfer zusammen
mit der russischen armee auf ihrem boden
haben auch
weitere soldaten dort haben soldaten im
zweiten weltkrieg und im großen
vaterländischen viel gekämpft
werden
an unsere streitkräfte innovation an die
widerstandskämpfer
dafür während des zweiten weltkrieges
nicht vergessen werden dass
nationalsozialismus keine chance haben
wir verneigen uns vor dem gedenken aller
die gestorben sind im zweiten weltkrieg
wir verneigen sich vor den töchtern vor
der schönen vor der blüte vor den vätern
vor den ehemännern
vor den brüdern vor den schwestern von
allen angehörigen der
verneigung vor
dem geht der iucn der menschen
erschossen
kameraden
die für unser land kämpfen
eine schweigeminute wird eingeläutet
also wir müssen mal ganz kurz wir gehen
jetzt einfach mal in die schweigeminute
rein weil die schweigeminute ist ein
propaganda schweigeminute wir müssen
einmal klarstellen dass putin hier im
prinzip 1 niederlage eingestanden hat
also erhält eine siegesrede ohne sieg er
kann nur sagen dass man für den sonnen
was kennt ziel der militärischen
sonderoperation wie man das in russland
nennen müssen war aber der regime
wechsel in kiew der fall der hauptstadt
und die großflächige einnahme des
schwarzmeer raums und des don was sie
jetzt kämpft man mühsam um den don was
nur noch den sonnenbrand das ist eine
und man ist statt in einem blitzkrieg
steht steckt man jetzt in einem wirklich
zu mögen den aufreibenden stellungskrieg
fest der sich über monate hinziehen kann
und der für russland tatsächlich auch
zur niederlage führen kann und wladimir
putin das müssen wir festhalten hat
nicht einen einzigen großen sieg zu
verkünden wir blicken hier auf die ewige
flamme die ist an der kremlmauer und wir
sehen hier vorne auch den russischen
doppeladler das ist das alte zahlungen
sind symbol der russischen doppeladler
jetzt geht es mit der und vielleicht
weil werte kameraden
der tod eines jeden soldaten und eines
jeden offizier muss unser gemeinsames
leid
es ist ein unwiederbringlicher
alle werden alles dafür tun um diesen
familien zu helfen und zu unterstützen
jede unterstützung zukommen lassen ich
habe ein entsprechendes dekret
unterzeichnet ich wünsche ihm baldige
genesung
ich bedanke mich bei allen die
ihren beitrag leisten ich verneige mich
vor ihnen das führt jedoch leben kämpfen
direkt an der front ohne sie selbst zu
schützen
kameraden wir sind hier auf dem roten
platz
wir sind hier schulter an schulter
viele soldaten sind hier aus
verschiedensten regionen unseres landes
einige von ihnen kamen direkt aus den
bars unmittelbar aus der kampfzone
wir erinnern uns daran wie
feinde unseres landes gegen uns
terroristen
wollten sie innerhalb unseres landes
feindseligkeiten sehen wollen aber sie
haben es nicht erreicht unsere kämpfer
verschiedenen nationalitäten kämpfen
seite an seite seite an seite schützen
gut gegenseitig das ist unsere stärke
die städte des landes
für das was unsere großväter versucht
haben zu verteidigen
das wohlergehen unseres heimatlandes ist
das wichtigste oder wichtigste ist
während unser wichtiges wert
und
die nationalsozialismus besiegt haben
damals im großen vaterländischen
großen
beispiel gezeigt
um unseren streitkräften auf unsere auf
russland auf unsere kurve
ja schließlich die hufe und
normalerweise
gewöhnlich auf dem roten platz genau das
passiert jetzt die nationalhymne
gespielt
gerade in diesen zeiten jetzt also wir
müssen natürlich normale wie diese rede
sprechen peter was mir aufgefallen ist
ja tatsächlich über tote und verletzte
geredet über gefallenen soldaten
besonderen gar nichts anderes übrig weil
bei der hohen anzahl von gefallenen
soldaten mindestens 15.000 sind tot es
gibt andere schätzungen die 15.000 sehr
konservative schätzung es gibt
schätzungen gehen weit über die 20.000
bis an die 30.000 das lässt sich nicht
mehr verheimlichen das kann auch nachdem
putin nicht unerwähnt lassen und an so
einem tag fällt ist dann leichter die
tatsächlich einzugestehen weil wenn man
von veteranen und von den gefallenen des
zweiten weltkrieges halte ich das wort
fisting der existierte in russland nicht
da gibt's so den großen vaterländischen
krieg wenn man von diesen gefallen
spricht dann kann man auch von den neuen
gefallen entsprechenden reiht man sie im
prinzip propagandistisch in die reihe
ein mann hat einmal gegen die
nationalsozialisten gekämpft jetzt
kämpft man gegen so genannte nazismus
das was uns immer ihre zurücklässt das
wieder davon gesprochen wird dass man
gegen nationalsozialisten kämpft mit dem
begriff werden inzwischen alle feinde
russlands gelabelt also dann wenn vom
nazismus die rede ist wenn von landowsky
die rede ist sind die ukraine gemeint
und ansonsten ist jeder feind russland
inzwischen ein nazi warum weil das in
russland in der sowjetunion immer gilt
gezogen hat wir allein gegen die nazis
viele hatten tatsächlich noch mehr
kriegsrhetorik erwartet noch mehr
aggression in richtung ukraine was heißt
das jetzt dass er sagen wir mal
vergleichsweise zurückhaltend wir wissen
nicht welche die kette er heute noch
unterschreiben wird aber wladimir putin
kann natürlich im dritten weltkrieg
erklären aber führen kann er ihn nicht
er hat nicht genügend soldaten er hat
nicht die technik er hat schlicht und
ergreifend überhaupt nicht die logistik
also wladimir putin bleibt momentan
weitestgehend nur maulheldentum aber wir
müssen immer wieder sagen auch wenn
nachher massenhaft technik über den
roten platz bereuen wird wenn wir hier
die parade schritt der das eine parade
regimentes sehen es ist und bleibt eine
verwundete nation lade mir putin ist ein
maulheld er stellt seit jahren waffen
vor die modernen sind und die aber in
serie nicht einsatzfähig sind oder die
bei abstürzen oder er hat einen modernen
tarnkappen bomber und ein jagdbomber die
57 die ist beim test abgestürzt und
selbst wenn die einsatzfähig wäre man
hat nicht in die moderne munition also
selbst mit dem modernen flugzeugen
müssen sie jede bombe ins ziel bringen
das heißt langsam und tief liegen sie
haben keine selbst lenken die munition
weil sie da auch dafür technik aus dem
aus dem westen brauchen also lade mir
putin es ist eine potemkinsche paradies
ist eine perverse parade gerade in
diesen zeiten aber der westen kann da
einigermaßen beruhigt drauf gucken weil
die ist kleiner als sonst oder die mit
putin hat nicht mehr die kraft schauen
wir noch mal wie die ukraine darauf
schaut paul ronzheimer wir haben jetzt
die rede gehört von wladimir putin hat
man in der ukraine da was aggressiveres
erwartet wie schätzt du das 1
ja ich glaube man muss erstmal darüber
sprechen was ist nicht passiert also es
gab während putins rede hier keinen
raketeneinschlag du hörst hinter mir die
glocken keinen serien alarm glocken also
das ist nicht passiert außerdem ist
nicht passiert bislang zumindest das ist
eine generalmobilmachung von putin gab
darüber wurde gesprochen in den
vergangenen wochen insbesondere vom
britischen verteidigungsminister der das
ins spiel gebracht hatte und das war die
debatte hier in den vergangenen tagen
wird putin dort jetzt sozusagen
offiziell krieg erklären also wird er
sagen dass aus der spezialoperation ein
krieg wird und damit eine
generalmobilmachung also mehr soldaten
die richtung donners geschickt werden
können auch das ist nicht passiert
ebenfalls hat putin nicht mehr über das
ziel gesprochen die ukraine als staat zu
vernichten also wir haben keine rhetorik
gehört die am anfang des krieges benutzt
hat wurde darüber gesprochen hat das ja
die ukraine als land nicht existiert
dass die ukraine auch russland sei also
das existenzrecht abgesprochen hat auf
diese rhetorik hat sich nicht wiederholt
also muss man sagen aus sicht von kiew
wenn man das militärisch analysiert und
wenn man davon ausgehen will dass das
was gut hin dort angekündigt hat
zumindest in den nächsten wochen oder
monaten auch bestand hat dann
konzentriert sich das ganze weiterhin
voll auf dem don bass und er sah sich
offenbar auch nicht imstande zumindest
bislang den sieg über mario pohl
feierlich zu erklären er kann an diesem
tag noch sehr viel passieren ich gehe
auch davon aus dass es noch
raketenangriffe im land geben wird aber
dieses ganz symbolische
während der militärparade diese große
nachricht diese große symbolkraft und
die große angst die man davor hatte die
hat sich zusammen zumindest bislang
nicht bestätigt also eine säge parade
ohne sieg quasi peter noch eine frage an
paul paul was rechnest du dennoch in
mario pohl also ich glaube ja dass nach
der parade hier auf dem roten platz doch
etwas passieren wird also endlich eine
parade in mario pohl oder aber angriffe
symbolische angriffen andere kann er ja
gar nicht machen weil er weil ihnen die
kraft fehlt aber symbolische angriffe
auf bestimmte zentren womit rechnet man
dann in kiew für den tag
davon geht man aus peter absolut man
rechnet damit dass es verschiedene
raketenangriffe im land noch geben wird
man rechnet damit dass man im donbass
besondere angriffe erleben wird wir
haben über den ort pro partner
gesprochen der eingenommen worden ist
wir haben das ja selbst in den
vergangenen zehn tagen dort erlebt
heftige kämpfe um die fk um das herum
dort am flughafen nur eins ist auch klar
und das ist etwas was diese offensive
ebendort so schwierig macht der krieg
dort im osten das muss man unseren
zuschauern ja immer wieder erklären der
geht eben seit 2014 und dort sind die
verteidigungsanlagen eben seit acht
jahren immer wieder verstärkt worden das
ist nicht so leicht und deshalb dieser
stellungskrieg also ich glaube aus kiew
perspektive ist man nach dieser rede von
putin etwas entspannter was den heutigen
tag angeht aber du hast natürlich
vollkommen recht die augen richten sich
auf mario pohl denn das ist das was die
ukrainische seele hier ja
wirklich schwer verwundet hat wenn man
mit den menschen spricht und wenn sich
dort die soldaten aus dem stahlwerk
melden es gibt dort diese bilder unser
kollege philipp jakob berichtet ja immer
wieder von dort und hat diese bilder
gegenüber von generälen zu beginn des
krieges und jetzt wenn man sich diese
gesichter anschaut was diese belagerung
mit ihnen gemacht hat und auch werden
jetzt die zivilisten aus als ob stahl
evakuiert worden sind ist eben die frage
was passiert mit denen soldaten und
diese soldaten sind für die ukraine
helden die dort so lange ausgehalten
haben deswegen gehe ich ganz stark davon
aus dass wladimir putin sowie die
richtung sagt noch irgendetwas in mario
pohl vor hat war für ihn dort ja eben
auch auf diese besondere rolle spielt
die ja immer wieder in eine
rechtsradikale
richtung gedrängt hat und gesagt hat das
sind diese nazis die wir vernichten
müssen und deswegen gehe ich davon aus
dass da noch etwas passiert